former US intelligence and analyst is
facing up to 50 years in prison for
allegedly leaking sensitive information
about Washington's covert drone warfare
program to the press guys name is Daniel
Hale he was arrested on Thursday he'd
served as a language analyst for the Air
Force between 2009 and 13 and in 2011 he
was also assigned to work for the
National Security Agency and given
top-secret security clearance therefore
now it's alleged that during that time
is when all this happened that he
established communication with a
reporter and then provided said reporter
the document stolen from NSA computers
Hale was indicted under the Espionage
Act on five charges related to the theft
their attention and the transmission of
classified information each carries a
maximum penalty of ten years in prison
the press freedom organization reporters
without borders far from happy with this
they've sharply criticized the arrest
arguing it represents a direct threat to
investigative journalism journalism with
more on the story this morning
here's caleb mopin many observers are
noting that the information provided in
the indictment seems to indicate that
it's possible he could be the person
that leaked information to the intercept
and reporter jeremy scahill that was
later published in his book the drone
papers however the intercept has refused
to confirm or deny that this was indeed
their source this is what was said by
the intercept the intercept does not
comment on matters relating to the
identity of anonymous sources these
documents detailed a secret
unaccountable process for targeting and
killing people around the world
including US citizens through drone
strikes they are of vital importance the
alleged whistleblower faces up to 50
years in prison no one has ever been
held accountable for killing civilians
in drone strikes now the information
that was published by the intercept
seems to indicate that there is a high
civilian death toll in the u.s. drone
warfare operations that have been waged
for the past 14 years in Afghanistan
Somalia and Yemen
they say the high death toll is due to
the fact that there is a preference for
killing targets rather than capturing
them furthermore it is difficult for US
intelligence agency
to extract the information they need
from terror suspects and those that they
have in custody the military is easily
capable of adapting to change but they
don't like to stop anything they feel is
making their lives easier worries to
their benefit but they have become so
addicted to this machine to this way of
doing business
that it seems like it's going to become
harder and harder to pull them away from
it the longer they're allowed to
continue operating in this way now there
has been quite an ugly history of the US
drone strike program many civilians have
been killed let's review some of what
has gone on as the u.s. carries out
targeted assassination with drones
[Music]
recently Chelsea Manning was released
from federal custody but it's expected
that she could return if she does not
testify against WikiLeaks furthermore
WikiLeaks founder Julian Assange is now
facing the possibility of being
extradited to the United States to face
charges of computer intrusion so many
are observing the situation saying
there's a big crackdown on
whistleblowers being carried out by the
US government
whatever tolerance there was for those
who leaked classified information about
government malfeasance seems to be gone
there is supposed to be a law actually
that prevents classification of
information evidencing a crime and so a
lot of the classification over
classification is actually to prevent
people from learning about crimes which
is completely illegal it's it's very
difficult to explain to people because
they don't understand that you're not
supposed to be able to commit a crime
and then be able to cover it up and
we've gone so far in pressing freedom of
speech and freedom of the press that
people really are pretty ignorant about
all of the stuff going on except for
this occasional you know documentary or
book written or newspaper article with
the help of whistleblowers and the
government is definitely trying to stop
all whistleblowing in all investigative
journalism that relies on any insider
information